Instructor: Just
learned that Babel takes our ES6
code and compiles it down to ES5
code, but that really only gets
us about half the way there.
Babel only works on syntax.
What do I mean by that? It only
works on the new syntax, like an
arrow function, or using
template strings, or any of the
const stuff that we've been
using. Those are all syntax.
That's just what our code looks
like and how it acts. The
other side of things is there is
a whole bunch of new methods
that we've learned about, where
those things aren't included in
Babel. What am I talking
about? Well, we've got here
Array.from(). That is a new
method and it's part of ES6. We
got that added to arrays and
we've looked at a whole bunch of
other methods that are new.
However, Babel doesn't convert
the Array.from() to something
else. It just assumes that you
have .from available on all of
your arrays. What you need to
do in a situation like this is
use what's called a polyfill. A
polyfill is very simple.
Essentially it says, if the
browser does not have it, we
must recreate it with regular
JavaScript. What I like to
do is, whenever I'm looking at a
method, MDN will always have a
polyfill for it inside of the
documentation. What it says is
if there is no Array.from()
method available, then they just
instantiate Array.from(), or
they put it on the prototype if
it's something that gets
inherited by every single array.
Array.from(), and you can take a
look that someone really smart
has figured out how to just re-
implement Array.from() without
actually having it in the
browser. What that allows us to
do is back port it to older
browsers, and that's really,
really nice. It's sort of a
pain to say, "What browsers do I
support? Do I need to use this
method or do I need to polyfill
it?" Rather than doing that, you
can just implement a polyfill
that will just figure it out all
for you. There's two major
polyfills that I like to tell
people to use. The first one is
using the Babel polyfill. This
uses something called core-js
which has a polyfill for every
single ES6 feature. All you need
to do, if you're using modules,
you just import Babel-polyfill.
You put that at the top of your
initial file, and what that's
going to do is include a whole
bunch of code which will
polyfill all of the older
browsers that you don't have.
That's great, but if you aren't
using modules, or if you really
don't need to polyfill all that
much, it can be a little bit of
code overhead that you don't
necessarily need, so there's
this other really great service
called polyfill.io. Let me go
over to the documentation right
here. This is really cool,
because what it does is, you
just include it with a script
tag on your page and then it
detects what browser is doing
the requesting. You don't decide, "
All right, who's visiting my
website and what do I need to
polyfill?" Polyfill.io says, "
All right, who's visiting and
what do they need polyfilled?"
If someone's visiting on IE9,
they're going to polyfill a
whole bunch of stuff. If
someone's visiting on latest
Chrome, they're probably not
going to polyfill all that much.
It's pretty cool. If we
actually go to polyfill.io and
copy the script tag here, put in
your URL bar and take off the .
min.js. What this is, is a
dynamically-generated JavaScript
file for my specific user agent,
for my specific browser.
What is it doing here? It's
actually really not polyfilling
all that much. It looks like
it's just polyfilling a bunch of
new properties, like .after,
append, before, prepend, and
replaceWith. These are all new
methods that are coming to our
elements. If I were to fake
this, if I were to fake IE9...
Let me open up my Chrome
DevTools here. If I go to this
little kabob, Network Conditions...
It's hidden deep inside of
Chrome DevTools, but we want to
change our user agent to
something like Internet Explorer
9. Watch me refresh this now.
Whoa, look what it's doing. It
detected that we are on IE9 --
or faking it -- and it's
polyfilling, look at, Array.from().
That's the one we were just
looking at. If you read this
code here, let's just search for
Array.from(). It will show us
the code here, and if there is
no Array.from() it's going to
polyfill that for us. It's going
to polyfill Array.of(), Array.
fill(), all of the element stuff,
all of the string .endsWith(), .
startsWith(), .includes(). We
went over all these, and now you
can use them in your older ones.
What I would recommend is go
ahead and just stick this sucker
in an HTML file. I'm going to go
into to my system.js file, and
just give yourself a script tag
and pop it in there, and you
don't have to worry about
anything evermore. If you are
worried about multiple requests
where you have to polyfill it
and then load your JavaScript,
then I might look at using the
Babel polyfill, where you just
include it all into one bundle.
It's totally up to you. One
other thing with Polyfill.io,
you can also tailor your
response so if you know you're
only using three or four ES6
methods and you don't want to
polyfill the entire ES6 feature
set for your IE9 visitors, you
can go ahead and tailor your own.
There's a whole bunch of options
that you can use here to
specifically request some of the
features that you want. You can
take a look here, and you can go
to the browser and the features
and look at every possible thing
that you want. Polyfilling,
along with transpiling with
Babel, is going to give you very
good coverage of all of your ES6
features.